taking down assassins hanging out with
gods jumping through time saving the
world so many times at its routine and
all this from one of the only avengers
with no powers here's hawkeye's entire
timeline in the mcu explained
baby clint was born in iowa to one edith
barton a headstrong lad he dropped out
of high school preferring to spend his
time working on his exceptional
marksmanship after maturing into
adulthood clint met and married a woman
named laura it was around that time that
clint's skills with weaponry of all
kinds drew the attention of nick fury
who personally handpicked him to be a
part of shield clint soon developed a
reputation as one of shield's most
skilled operatives and one of fury's
most trusted men when clint and laura
decided to start a family fury helped
keep their personal data out of shield's
files and also found a farmhouse for the
couple in missouri to raise their
children away from the eyes of their
enemies
during his early years in shield clint's
work was fraught with danger after
becoming known as one of shield's most
dangerous agents the increasingly
infamous archer found himself in the
crosshairs of the many international
criminal organizations that shield was
in the business of stopping one of the
criminal organizations hired a man
called marcus scarlotti an assassin and
one of the most dangerous men in the
world the details of clint and
scarlotti's battle have remained mostly
a mystery but we do know that scarletti
came closer to killing clint than any
other opponent had before
marcus scarlotti was behind the attack
an assassin almost killed barton a few
years back
clint himself was also unable to take
down scarletti and the master assassin
continued to operate from the shadows
after becoming one of shield's top
agents hawkeye was assigned increasingly
complex missions of an international
nature for one such mission clint was
assigned the task of locating and
eliminating a dangerous new russian
assassin called black widow who was
stated to be a threat to global peace
clint managed to track down black widow
in russia where she turned out to be one
natasha romanov during their
interactions clint realized that there
was a potential for good in natasha who
had been forced to become black widow by
a clandestine russian program called red
room instead of killing her clint
offered natasha the chance to defect
from russia and become a shield
operative natasha accepted the deal and
she and clint teamed up to put an end to
the red room once and for all to that
end they tracked down draycol the leader
of the red room to a secret location in
budapest
natasha and clint arranged to bomb the
building drakov was operating from as a
result special forces pursued clinton
natasha forcing them to engage in a
brutal fire fight before hiding out for
10 days in the ceiling of a subway
station mujraikov supposedly dead
natasha officially joined shield and
became clint's partner on many new
missions as well as his close friend
just like budapest all over again
you and i remember budapest very
differently
years later clint was instructed by nick
fury to go down to new mexico to help
investigate a strange object that was of
special interest to shield arriving at
the site in 2011's thor clint was joined
by agent phil coulson and put in charge
of watching over the facility which
housed the object a hammer-shaped
construct that no one seemed to be able
to lift from his vantage point clint
watched an unknown blonde hulking man
tear through the guards protecting the
facility and make his way to where the
hammer was located clint had the
intruder in his bow's crosshairs but
coulson ordered him to wait so they
could see what the blonde stranger later
revealed to be thor odenson would do
with the hammer clint was witness to
thor's initial failure to lift the
hammer he also saw jane foster leaving
the facility and allowed them to leave
so thor and jane could be secretly
tracked later clint witnessed thor
regain his power and battle the
destroyer sent by loki after thor won
clint helped transport the body of the
destroyer to a secret shield facility
after the events of new mexico hawkeye
was tasked with breaking into shield's
helicarrier as a means of testing the
giant machine's defenses upon breaking
through the last level of security clint
obtained secret files pertaining to
something called the avengers initiative
soon afterward clint was put in charge
of the security detail for project
pegasus a team founded to explore the
nature of the tesseract that had been
previously used during the cree squirrel
war in the 1980s fury brought in thor's
friend eric selvig to examine the
powerful object as shown in 2012's the
avengers clint saw the tesseract as a
doorway through space and reasoned that
the doorway could be open from both
sides that was when the test rack
started acting up and clinton and
security team were caught unaware by
loki's arrival in the ensuing battle
clint managed to save fury's life but at
the cost of becoming a mind controlled
slave to loki along with selvig
still under loki's thrall clint helped
to create a method of disrupting the
tesseract using iridium technology loki
wanted to test earth's mightiest
warriors in preparation for ruling earth
to that end the god of mischief allowed
himself to be captured and brought on
board the helicarrier that also
contained the entire avengers team while
loki distracted the people on the
helicarrier with his mind games clint
led an aerial assault against a
helicarrier itself he almost succeeded
in taking down the giant machine but was
brought back to his senses at the last
minute by black widow
why am i back
how'd you get him out
cognitive recalibration
i hit you really hard in the head
now free of loki's mind control clint
vowed to make up for his earlier actions
by aiding the newly formed avengers in
their fight against the god of mischief
clint joined the other heroes in the
battle against loki's alien army in new
york he was able to hold off the army
long enough to fire an exploding arrow
at loki which briefly took the villain
out of the battle finally hawkeye and
the other avengers combined their forces
to stop loki's army imprison the god of
mischief and stepped out of the shadows
to become heroes for all mankind
clint was now officially a member of the
avengers after the battle of new york
the team of heroes learned that loki's
enchanted scepter had passed into the
hands of prominent hydra agent baron
strucker strucker had already used the
scepter to carry out experiments on
humans with the most successful products
of such testing being wanda maximoff and
her brother pietro while the avengers
managed to retrieve the scepter at the
start of 2015's avengers age of ultron
wanda slipped a bit of hypnosis into
tony stark's psyche to make him paranoid
with the help of bruce banner tony began
work on an ai named ultron that could
defend humanity against any alien
threats the ai eventually broke free of
tony's programming and became sentient
ultron decided that humanity needed to
be destroyed meaning that clint and the
other avengers once again had to step up
to save the world after a long and
hard-fought battle during which clint
was forced to reveal the existence of a
secret family farm to the other avengers
they were able to destroy ultron
pietro died while saving clint and wanda
became an ally to the heroes
a new member was also added to the team
in the form of tony's former ai butler
turned sentient cyborg vision
after these major battles hawkeye was
starting to become uncomfortably aware
that he was hopelessly outmatched in
battles against literal gods and
monsters in the days leading up to the
final assault against ultron clint
promised his wife that he would retire
from active duty if he managed to make
it through the next battle intact once
ultron was gone clint made good on his
promise and made it back home in time
for the birth of his third child
nathaniel pietro barton who was named
after natasha and pietro despite trying
to enjoy retirement clint didn't find
regular activities much fun clearly
retirement doesn't suit you you got
tired of shooting golf
well i played 18. shot 18.
this can't seem to miss
clint then learned about the creation of
the sokovia accords and how the question
of signing the accords had led to
infighting between the avengers during
the events of 2016's captain america
civil war feeling compelled to help his
friends clint came out of retirement to
fight at captain america's side this
eventually led to clint becoming a
fugitive from the law and being taken
into custody by the military along with
cap's other allies
even though captain america broke clint
and the others out of prison soon after
the events of civil war they were still
wanted fugitives clint decided to turn
himself into the fbi and agree to the
sokovia accords in return for being
placed under house arrest on his own
farm instead of being imprisoned glenn
spent his house arrest bonding with his
children and teaching archery to his
daughter lila who showed talent with the
bow and arrow herself while clint was
enjoying his down time with his family
in 2018 his life was turned upside down
yet again when his wife and children
mysteriously disappeared in his very
presence he would later come to learn of
thanos's mission to eradicate half of
all life in the universe and how the mad
titan's victory had resulted in the
death of untold trillions at the end of
adventures infinity war
having lost his family clint grew
increasingly unstable he took the fact
that so many criminals survived the snap
that killed his family and many other
innocents as a personal insult
clint decided to get back into active
duty this time as the vigilante known as
ronin now armed with a sword clint waged
a brutal war against the criminal
underworld of new york having killed
every villain he could find in the city
ronin turned his attention to the
mexican cartel in 2019's avengers end
game james rhodes aka war machine
described clint's actions in mexico to
natasha in chilling terms the
federalists found a room full of bodies
looks like a bunch of cartel guys never
even had a chance to get their guns off
still thirsting for vengeance clint then
made his way to japan to take down the
yakuza crime syndicate after eliminating
the mafia group clint realized natasha
had found him and after a somber
conversation clint allowed nat to take
him back to the avengers headquarters to
figure out a plan to bring everyone back
from the snap
clint agreed to help the avengers with
their plan to go back in time to collect
the six infinity stones before thanos
and make their own infinity gauntlet he
was the first to volunteer to test the
new time traveling technology using
ant-man's pym particles to successfully
travel back in time to his farm with his
family inside now convinced the plan
could work clint helped the other
avengers decide on a plan of action to
retrieve the infinity stones clinton
natasha were tasked with getting the
soul stone on the planet vormir arriving
at the location they discovered that one
needed to sacrifice the other in order
to find the stone clint insisted he'd be
the one to sacrifice himself but natasha
managed to beat him to the punch
devastated over the loss of his best
friend clint returned to the avengers
headquarters with the soul stone as the
other teams brought each of the other
five stones
banner was able to use them to snap
everyone who had disappeared five years
ago back into existence including
clint's family but natasha was gone for
good
before the avengers could celebrate
their victory the thanos from the past
arrived in the present bombing the
avengers headquarters in an attempt to
get the infinity stones clint regrouped
with the other heroes as they prepared
to make a final stand against thanos
clint got to the gauntlet first and he
continued to protect it from thanos army
while being aided by the other heroes
thanos tried to get his hands on the
gauntlet but iron man managed to
retrieve the infinity stones and use
them to snap the mad titan and his army
away despite their victory clint spent
the next few days mourning the loss of
black widow and attending the funeral of
tony stark clint also reconnected with
his old friend juan maximoff and
comforted her over the loss of vision at
long last barton was able to return to
his family on their farm
after the events of avengers infinity
war clint distanced himself from the
avengers once again and tried to put his
past as a crime fighter behind him he
was living with his family on their farm
when he was invited to attend a musical
based on the chittari invasion which he
and the avengers thwarted years earlier
clint took his kids to the show but he
was unable to enjoy it due to the many
inaccuracies in being reminded of
natasha's demise why is everyone singing
and dancing about everything i don't
know was frequently accosted by hawkeye
fans whenever he went out in public and
he felt uncomfortable with all the
attention all he wanted to do was enjoy
the holiday festivities with his
children in new york before returning
home but his plans changed after he saw
a troubling news report someone was
using his old ronin assassin uniform to
terrorize the city still haunted by his
time as ronin clint decided to set off
on a quick secret mission to nab his
doppelganger and get his old suit back
before things got out of hand
clint discovered that the mysterious
person who had taken over his ronin
identity was kate bishop a young
vigilante fighting a tense battle
against a crime syndicate called the
tracksuit mafia wanting to know more
clint intervened on kate's behalf and
helped her get away when clint began to
interrogate kate about her use of the
ronin suit he discovered that kate had
been inspired by the events of the
chitauri invasion when she witnessed
hawkeye fighting alongside the other
avengers on an even footing this
convinced kate that you don't need
superpowers to be a hero and she devoted
her life to becoming a master archer
like her idol clint made it clear that
the ronin persona was no joke and kate
revealed to him that she'd found the
ronin costume during a black market
auction held by a mysterious and
powerful criminal clint then warned kate
that ronan had made a lot of dangerous
enemies over the years and that they
would all be coming after her
kate and clint's private moment was
interrupted by the tracksuit mafia's
assault on their hiding place the duo
managed to escape but clint felt
hampered by the lack of his usual
arsenal along with his worry for kate
and his desire to get back to his family
meanwhile the ronin suit had once again
disappeared but clint discovered that it
was in the possession of a group of
live-action role players he also found
out that kate came from a powerful
family with a sketchy background despite
her wanting to work alongside him clint
opted to complete the rest of his
mission on his own and sent kate back to
her family after assuring his wife that
he would be home soon clint set out to
hunt down the ronin costume alone
unfortunately clint was still being
followed by the tracksuit mafia who were
initially recruited to get their hands
on a special rolex watch that belonged
to his wife it would come to learn that
the villains were acting on behalf of a
woman named maya lopez aka ekko who held
a personal grudge against clint for
killing her father during his time as
ronan
clint said about uncovering the true
nature of the tracksuit mafia's attack
on him and kate and determined that the
mafia was actually being run by the
powerful wilson fisk aka kingpin bisk
didn't want to get involved in a fight
with an avenger but maya's personal
vendetta was all that mattered to her
clan also found himself bonding with
kate and warming up to her enthusiastic
views on hawkeye from wanting clint to
improve his brand to coming up with new
trick arrows kate even took glenn home
to meet her family but her mother
eleanor became concerned that her
daughter was getting mixed up in
dangerous circles i mean she's pretty
good at all this guy natasha romanoff
was pretty damn good at wasn't she while
trying to get the drop on the tracksuit
mafia clint was ambushed by an assassin
who turned out to be elena bolova who
held clint responsible for the death of
her sister natasha by trying to end
things with the tracksuit mafia and
investigating the true nature of the
company run by kate's parents elaine
proved to be another major obstacle that
forced glenn to rely on kate's help once
again with his enemies closing in around
him clint revealed to maya that wilson
fisk had orchestrated events so that
ronin would kill her father because fisk
saw maya's dad as a threat the savvy
villain had used ronin to get rid of his
competition manipulating the situation
to his benefit clint also finally had it
out with elena telling her the truth
about natasha's death and spoke about
how devastated he was over the loss of
his friend at long last elena believed
clint's story and the two grieved over
the death of natasha together meanwhile
kate discovered that her mother eleanor
was secretly working with kingpin to pay
off an old debt after a narrow escape
kate was able to take down fisk and
regretfully handed her mother over to
the authorities with the whole affair
finally put to rest clint asked kate to
spend christmas at the farm with his
family he returned the rolex to his wife
and suggested to his new protege that
they should share the name hawkeye going
forward
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel superheroes are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you